[Music]
hello everyone Perry here with an
exclusive Collider interview thanks to
the kiyose upper suite in Park City
we've got the folks behind never rarely
sometimes always I finally did it I feel
like people are probably having a tough
time kind of congratulations well the
movie made quite the impression so I
feel like I had to get it right and I
was ready to get it right so excited to
have you guys here today I have to make
you do it Eliza though the 101 oh one on
the movie for folks out there who do not
know what this one's about yeah so the
film is called never rarely sometimes
always and it's about a teenage girl in
rural Pennsylvania played by Sydney
Flanagan and her name is autumn and she
is dealing with an unintended pregnancy
and because of the consent laws in rural
Pennsylvania she is forced to travel
with her cousin play by Talia rider to
New York City to find an abortion clinic
and the girls spend 48 hours in New York
navigating a crisis and a city that
they've never been to you're gonna do
that like 20 more times today and that
was a great start you nailed it
so as a you are a Sundance pro first
time for the to you though did you or do
you have any advice for them to make the
most of the experience at the festival
um I think you know it's it's always
hard the first time I think and it's
exciting and I think you just have to go
with the flow and we're really lucky
that the reception of the film has been
so wonderful so I think we're all just
kind of sailing good energy and first
features for both of you Sydney I'll
start with you because I was reading in
the press notes that when this
opportunity came up you might not have
been super into jumping into a feature
film at the very beginning so why did
you feel that way and then what changed
her mind
um well at first I got the email and I I
wasn't sure if it was real or not so
that was part of it but also I had never
really considered myself an actor I'd
never acted before I was a musician
and I don't know I I said something I'm
like oh I'm so busy with my band and my
job but I worked at a supermarket so it
was kind of an excuse and then I had
Skyped with Eliza and then I was like
okay I guess I'll just read the script
and you know tape the audition like why
not but after reading the script I was
just so drawn like how powerful of a
story it was and I'm like how like real
and truthful the characters were and I
was like I don't know I just like had to
do it
was it a similar situation for you Talia
or when this opportunity came up you're
like I mean no matter what yeah and the
first time I read the script it was kind
of the same realization that Sydney had
I hadn't seen a story like this before
and after reading how truthful the
characters were I knew that this was
something I had to be a part of having
been through the whole process at this
point if you guys could go back and give
yourself one piece of advice for making
this first feature film what would it be
hmm that's a tough question um I don't
know I I was good about like documenting
and writing things down and like taking
in the whole experience so I don't know
I think maybe just like chill out a
little bit don't stress that so much
yeah I think I would have like tried to
find better ways to get more sleep
that's a that's a fair thing to have to
learn on the on set there Eliza what is
step one
after you cast these two roles because
you know we only get to spend one
feature film with these characters and
they have to express a significant
amount of history between the two of
them so how do you make sure that's
established before you guys had set we
had so little time and it's one of the
biggest challenges of making an
independent film is that you don't get a
rehearsal period like you would doing a
play you don't get to spend time in a
space working with everyone bringing
everyone together and establishing you
know trust and you know a group dynamic
so you know that was a big challenge I
had about a day and a half with Sydney
and Talia to rehearse and what I did was
I wanted them to have a secret history
you know that only they knew
and a bomb that were you know existed
between them I'm set and nobody else on
the crew so I gave them each a notebook
and I wrote down some writing prompts
that were very personal and I left them
alone and let them write and share and
they you know through that exercise I
think got to know each other and you
know realized they had so much in common
and were able to form you know a
connection just because you are both
fairly new to the scene I want to ask
you this and you know make each other
blush can you each tell me something
about the other just I don't know a
hobby and interest you know something
that makes you super passionate about
filmmaking the movie that got you into
it anything at all I don't know Sydney's
a really really talented musician and
the first time that we hung out and we
did that writing prompt she she showed
me her album it was on Apple music and I
remember like the train ride home I like
I was listening because I listen to
music on the train I put it in and I was
like holy [ __ ] with this girl and she's
just so talented I remember being really
impressed with Thalia and how much she
had done like for her age and I thought
that was like super cool and she's also
just like a really light hearted person
and so easy to be around
and she also has a great sense of style
I love that so now we know a little bit
about you guys I am curious though I
asked us a lot because I love learning
about other members of the crew who
really contributed and there was one
person in particular I'm curious if you
bring up that I was reading about in the
press notes but if you had a name and
unsung hero of the production someone
who was really instrumental to bringing
this film to screen so successfully who
would you each pick and why tricky
because it really took an army to put
the movie together so it's hard to
really single one person I will say that
I'm Matt Rose Garnett who works for the
BBC at a coffee shop or like a
restaurant in London when I was
premiering be chats and it was one of
the most lovely kind of short meetings
and she said what do you want to do next
I said this is what I want to do and she
got behind it immediately and it was a
very transparent and supportive and
trusting collaboration and I've just
never had something so flawless and
effortless I guess and she's a magnetic
human being and really helped motivate
and inspire other people to take the
project seriously I'd say for me it was
probably a couple of the PAS
because they were there with me a lot of
the time the drives to set and home and
going around and they were like the
people I could talk to you and then
we're always like supportive and there
for me you know and like all the
in-between moments however I would say
the same - I mean yes please yes please
okay definitely one of them would be
Nikki I'm not sure if I remember all
their last names right now Nikki Bruno
and then also I've showed Alejandro the
assistant director because he was so
amazing but there's just so many people
I can name and it's just like all of
them
created such a great environment to be
in to do something so new and stressful
you know yeah same also Helen who worked
in crafty I don't know they just made
being on set so much fun what was the
key to Helen making an impression I cry
because I really do genuinely feel like
craft services very undervalued and
that's such an important thing about
keeping you going throughout the day so
how did Helen make your day I know she
always got us like dope snacks we were
just like hang out and just chill all
the time I was really fun yeah she was a
awesome person yeah I wrote her a poem
as a wrap gift and she was definitely a
favorite yeah the name I was thinking
about from the press notes that I was
reading was Kelly yes I was thinking
that one of you were gonna bring her up
can you tell me about her impact on the
film as well you mean Kelly Chapman yes
yes yeah Kelly Chapman I met while doing
research at an abortion clinic in Queens
called choices and you know I've been
supplying
and I'm I was really sort of taken with
Kelly Chapman and she was very candid
with me about her experiences and what
it's like to be on the receiving end of
so many people coming in and she's a
counselor and it was a lot a lot of what
she said that inspired parts of the
narrative and she said something really
that stuck with me while I was
researching she said you know the
abortion is never the crisis it's the
mystery of what's going on at home and
what they're you know what they're
dealing with which you can't fix in that
hour in which they come into the clinic
and that mystery of what's going on at
home really kind of became central to my
approach and writing the scripts that
concept like runs through the veins of
the entire movie though so it came
through very successfully I also wanted
to ask you a little bit about your shot
selection specifically something that
comes up later in the movie and I won't
spoil the details of the scene but it's
where the title comes from and you don't
traditionally cut back and forth like
one might in a conversation like that so
do you find a moment like that on set do
you plan it that way or do you find it
in the edit that scene was planned to be
shot as a long take and part of our kind
of strategy for shooting was to use two
cameras - while we were shooting it was
very tight on Sydney there's one camera
here one camera here and it was almost a
tactic to you know to intensify the
pressure of the scene and you know we
shot on 16 millimeter and when you do a
long take on a digital camera it's
meaningless you can delete it you can do
it again but when you shoot a long take
on 16 millimeter there's a heightened
risk to it and you know that was the
strategy for for shooting the scene it
we could have played that whole scene in
one long tape but for a little bit of
context we cut - Kelly the counselor but
you know it was a strategy that we had
had from the beginning and yeah it's
really
it's really you know to me was so
important that it be as natural and as
confrontational as possible
a risk well worth taking it's a very
powerful moment thank you guys so much
for your time today thank you I hope you
guys enjoy
Sundance again huge congratulations on
the movie never airlie sometimes always
keep an eye out for it
another huge thank you to the supper
suite for having us this year in Park
City
please don't leave this interview
without liking and sharing it we'll see
you soon with more interviews